a great play by itself could be amazing
but a great play with great castings can
be legendary
the right casters make eSports even
better
so we salute the hard-working casters of
the dota 2 world with the top 10 best
dota 2 caster college kicking off our
list in style at number 10 we have the 6
million dollar echo slam PPG he comes
the ice floss
[Applause]
the play itself is phenomenal basically
winning eg ti5 and the piles of cash
that went with it but it's Toby wants
extremely Australian pronouncement of
cdc's fate that makes this one of the
best calls of all time PPT here comes
the ice blah serenity
[Applause]
at number nine we have the call
accompanying note I'd hunters
revolutionary Roshan bait at Dreamhack
winter 2012 in case anyone at home
didn't realize how amazing this gambit
was Toby Wan made it clear with the call
that's almost as famous as the Roshan
bait itself huh game is on the bait is
Lane there's a small blood patch where
Admiral bullet jammed and it is actually
trapped because they came to check for
it then the stun big guys I don't know
they can I bring it down
oh boy James now will the beat is this
we may pull something out of the bag 10
feet is gonna go down as well Oh hunter
water stop what a strategy coming out
from material Envy the Prophet bait he
doesn't lose any gold anything by
suiciding to Russia it's a pure fate he
spent all his gold on standing on him
and no China just come right out get two
kills right off the bat no one has ever
done that no one has ever done that in
the history of dota
though neither team would go on to win
ti3 the lower bracket slugfest between
Team Liquid and LGD gaming and LG's
famous shouts takes number eight the
final fight over lgd's ancient was
certifiably insane and the mania
infected the casters as they described
the blow-by-blow action in legendary
fashion they're going for the throat
they say no more messing around
whoa LGD make a great place I'll are
coming in Oh invivo goes up as you slow
son Bob relax Mike there's no art piece
here can they really stop this fight
without any art piece the thrones gonna
start dropping soon tier 4 is to fall
one down one to go
you may go now silo need to fight the
CFI back he got a buyback now the throw
under siege
therefore towers going down vkp saw over
a number team liquid and silo this
canopy is laughs robbing boba he's
looking for more hooks they fights two
more now silent man fight cheese gets
pop on TC they're going for the kill we
have RP in 20 seconds will there be
twenty more seconds I'm not sure if
Sylar going for TC Toby ones bombastic
excitement is infectious and he has a
talent for describing plays with turns
or freeze straight out of Little House
on the Prairie
so on number 7 we have Toby's quirky
reaction to this massive team fight
between DK and orange eSports then
stocking up on booze cheek sentry Ward's
giving I have a crack there's are some
emotions they cannot bring it down add a
page script on cans an upper high is
only too much like oh he's got a ball
because the whole cat caboodle
Hilal a budding flower life dog dead yet
though
be still alive there's losing life
quickly fall stopped away Hill
he'll live a super will not but she's in
there for self away super of the team
yet they find him they don't they turn
another case of Toby wants Australian
accent and folky sings creating a
legendary moment number six comes in
from the recent the bout between cloud
nine and scary faces in star series
season twelve and twenty thirteen
remains the longest pro game in history
at three hours 20 minutes and 34 seconds
it was certainly a little more than what
OD pixel and purge bargained for and
they more than earned a spot at number
five for their efforts over the course
of the game the duo took the
ridiculousness in stride
despite obviously getting Haggard as the
game went on and on and on bonus points
go to OD who enlisted the aid of his
sound board to play epic music to raise
the energy whenever a team fight broke
out haze the fight there's the dream
call a pistol braid though
echo sounds of misery this is it ladies
and gentleman this is it here's the
final fight team a shootout all day but
I've seen us die let's stop the music
now that's not fun a fine here
it's tough to be on your game for more
than three hours and the excitement was
real when sfz rush c nines ancient at
just over 200 minutes in and brought the
ordeal to a close
backing back into the fight they got a
good for the chip fortification it's
gotta be JJ let's see that one there lay
the game oh my god a call as legendary
as the play it accompanied number four
is the moment referred to solely as the
play casters LD and luminous did an
excellent job breaking down one of the
defining moments in all of dota and LD
speech has become something of a
copypasta in the DOTA community patients
from zone waiting in the wave now he's
about to be caught oh there's the sleep
that sir he catches everyone oh this
could be a total disaster
like Danny
you better turn around
that's one trying to survive
Schwantz gonna go down puppy talked
about the nagas counter it's why the
Bevin with us pkp they turn it around I
don't even know how they're gonna do it
standing ovation from the crowd the last
I'll be going great moment sleeve
equally excellent casting and the play
delivers on all fronts some would say
dirty humor is cheap comedy however
sometimes a perfectly placed cuss can
elevate two moments into the realm of
legend as our pick for number three
proves the triple die back to shut down
how does one condense all the action all
the drama all the sheer emotion of puck
dodging an auto-attack in a single
weirdly pronounced exclamation of
excitement just ask LD whose infamous
over-exaggeration
takes number two on the list Oh DD
picked up Ferrari on the backfoot
puppy is doing it left right and center
making things happen Ferrari
that's the facia he's gotta use it soon
he will wow the windows timing there
about point zero zero five seconds and
he pulls it off I needed to do so the
International 2013 was a special
tournament and so it was only fitting
that its grand finals is one of the best
series ever played in dota 2 history it
was a grueling five-game epic and the
casters were at their best for every
twist and turn right up until the bitter
end capping off our list is the closing
moments of this legendary series
[Music]
now if they go over the phone
it could be game Bunnings down Alliance
aren't doing as they need a little far
to fall in jeopardy
that's a glint it could be their last
stand
then these baggies gonna try to focus
everybody but there's so much stuff
there's no more clips available does
about half HP a code range be a lion
surrounding from all sides can be free
the alloys just one 1.4 million dollars
they are
International strange happiness they've
taken off the first ever international
for this week and there you have it did
we miss any of your favorite calls let
us know in the comments below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button